an hour's drive north of the spanish
city of malaga lies this lagoon home to
one of the largest flamingo colonies in
europe
it's been a protected area for nearly
four decades and the birthplace for more
than two hundred thousand chicks
hundreds of volunteers flocked to the
fuente de pietera lagoon every year to
help tag the birds
after the two-year biological halt we
had because of kovid of course people
came with a lot of hope to participate
they have been happy to repeat the
tagging after three years
flamingos are born gray and develop
their signature color from the plants
and algae they eat
the chicks are guided into a pen then
carefully fitted with a ring before the
release to rejoin their colony
the tags enable conservationists to
monitor their movements around the world
thanks to this kind of tagging we know
whether these animals are eating in
france libya morocco or here in spain
it also provides vital information about
the birds mating habits and lifespan
but climate change is having a negative
impact on their natural habitats
saltwater lakes are drying up and during
a drought birds struggle to build their
nests which are made of mud making them
less likely to mate
a very dry past few years the lagoon has
started to show its layer of salt with
no water thankfully there are spots
handled by the nature reserve's water
supplies which allows the flamingo
colony and other birds to survive
the warming temperatures in reserves
like these make survival of the fittest
all the more real
jillian wolf al jazeera